thank you
[Music]
Michael O'Hare oh The Blind Side ah the
airport in Chicago O'Hare
right wait I was right
that's such a bully move I talk about
that lady
you said Michael oh yeah The Blind Side
family yeah ending their 19-year
conservatorship for Michael O'Hare
and here's the thing and yes this is the
family who inspired Sandra Bullock's
2009 drama The Blind Side is that the
the football boy yeah more like a man
but yes do you know the way it's not
isn't that the high school kid yeah
kind of it's not a man
oh it's been a 19-year conservatorship
was it because the he needed help to get
adopted
he was homeless basically and they you
know this very very wealthy family did
take him in and provide for him and
stuff and gave him a much more
comfortable lifestyle he ended up being
able to go to high school and became
like a very very first round NFL draft
pick type of person super super
successful
I'm giving you props which is which is
like weird so suspicious what the [__]
what's the joke say the joke I got
something on my teeth I didn't watch the
movie but I saw the trailer I just want
them to know ah what a thoughtful guy
yeah they owned a bunch of Taco Bell
franchises in the movie yeah
they still they have won a ton of
different foods she drove a white Range
Rover in the movie I think the dad was a
football coach
a lot of rich white ladies they love
White Range Rovers yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah and like white room
sunglasses so he's saying that they
never actually adopted him they tricked
him into signing a conservatorship
instead of an adoption so he is now
filing a lawsuit against them for that
wait what yeah why now so in February
this year O'Hara allegedly learned that
he'd never legally been adopted by the
twoies uh I believe I'm pronouncing that
semi-clubby as he claimed to believe
that the case um this was the case when
he signed documents 19 years ago in
reality the documents meant that tuis
would become O'Hara's conservators
conservatores uh O'Hare filed a lawsuit
against the family in which he accused
them of deceiving him over his legal
family status and of exploiting his life
or financial gain so
one is like Britney Spears and her
father right where he is the manager
yeah and then he's that's a conservative
that was also a conservative and then it
was a conservatorship right it's like if
someone's in charge of your finances so
you don't melt your whole life away like
okay okay
and then so they started with the
conservative
before he was even adopted and he's not
even adopted he thought he thought it
was adoption just straight up but it was
just it was a conservatorship they start
making money off of him well one of the
ways is that well aside from we don't
know what happened prior but like The
Blind Side movie yeah apparently they
were making money off of that and he
wasn't getting anything oh that sucks do
you think Sandra Bullock is a little
embarrassed he wasn't getting long-term
pay at least we know that we don't know
if he got like a lump sum in the
beginning or some [__] but I don't know
I'm like uh if you paid to feed them
house them
that is one of the definite arguments so
like he was basically homeless and then
now he and you know they were worth I
think their evaluation was like over a
hundred million dollars at the point at
which they took him in so it's not like
they needed money from this homeless kid
it's not like there was a guarantee that
he was going to provide some sort of
financial gain then why not adopt him
the family made money directly from the
movie it said something about the movie
paid royalties to the original writer of
the book that the movie is based on and
that writer of the book shared the
royalties with the family I don't know
if it's like they directly got paid so
the question is is that normal if
someone takes a kid in they go the route
with conservatorship like what is what
is it there's like something that has to
do with like finances that they were
trying to look at because maybe with
adoption there's more like yeah red tape
yeah something I think they might have
maybe I'm guessing he he might have
because in the movie he he doesn't seem
like he's that smart do they have enough
do they have their own maybe they were
trying to like help him by being like oh
let us take control of all this like
extra stuff so that you don't get duped
into doing something else
intentions
but there are good intended conservators
adoption also changes the relationship
the legal relationships and stuff too
well it actually benefits them for taxes
abortion I mean uh adoption but then oh
[__]
if they're hella wealthy right they
already have grown kids they don't want
to split the inheritance with the kit
that they adopt so they're like you know
what you can be a part of the family in
in this way but
um it's their way to protect themselves
The Inheritance is it's it's it's it's
thought of differently yeah yeah there
could be different I don't know man it's
harder yeah it sounds like when you're
this Rich there's a lot of weird I don't
think it's a personal decision I think
they have a lawyer and the lawyer goes
well here's what makes more sense blah
blah blah blah ABCDE and they just do it
I don't think this kid this is what we
have yeah yeah exactly I think and if
you're a lawyer you're not looking at it
emotionally you're like well it makes
more logical sense for you to be
concerned you don't know this kid you
can bring them in and then he turns 18
he's no longer you can't like wouldn't I
don't know Lynn like let's say when
Ballers male and female get together and
it's their third marriage right they
have to deal with so much carving out
things on their will for their own uh
kids from different relationships they
don't just muddy it up into one group
yeah maybe so then there's like all
these weird
things they have to deal with just it
depends on what they told the kid how
old was he when he was uh adopted or
brought into the family but what also
doesn't make any sense to me is if they
did profit and benefit and he didn't see
any of those proceeds that's weird
that's really weird there's two kind of
things that are important here
um again this comes after the former NFL
star launched a lawsuit against his
legal Guardians claiming that the family
made Millions off of him through his
story being told in the 2009 film so
that is a claim but then there's also
the other side where Michael O'Hare also
threw that entire thing and the
popularity of it he also wrote a book
about this and financially benefited
from that as well let alone was an NFL
star you know what I'm saying so like
also had his own
version of success yeah you know what
I'm saying so it's like and then did he
share that success with them
like who knows it's hard too it's hard
to assume that the family did it for
financial game with seeing how well off
they are they are they're worth 100
million dollars at the time people with
a lot of money do be doing greedy [__]
yeah yeah so it's like you see
opportunities yeah it's like and that
could be a possibility right it may be
also two things could be true at the
same time
when he uh got adopted by them in high
school
um not in the movie he's like what is he
like a a preteen or what the hell is he
in the movie I don't even remember but
he also said the movie made him look
dumb and he was pissed about that all
right well if I was if I was hand what
if he was really done if I was him
and I was a Jon Snow Yeah right adopted
all like they took care of me they
helped me get to this point got me the
best coaches all this stuff right
I would actually carve out a portion of
my income and give that to them as a way
of thanks because you invested into me
so then if that was me
but then also on the flip side if I was
the family that took him in I would take
him in as if you're my own son so it's
like you're my Jon Snow and I'm putting
you in my will
um and then you don't have to pay me
anything because I'm your father
so that's my philosophy between like how
I would deal with my family but that's
to me it's weird what was Jon Snow's
dad's name again not the real dad
is adopted dad uh Stark yeah John star
um
so he was he was 18 when he entered the
conservative ship which is now coming to
an 19 years on uh though The Blind Side
would eventually win Sandra Bullock and
Oscar the attorneys claimed that the
family didn't earn much from their
on-screen portrayal uh quote well each
member of the family has received the
same amount of money so imagine a pie
being divided by five okay we estimate
each person received a hundred thousand
dollars so that's also the legal nice
pie still yeah from from their side
yeah also what what advantages are like
if if it was at age 18 that he got the
conservatorship that's a little old to
be adopted too like nothing changes
right oh maybe that's why because he was
18 right and if they're trying to help
him with his life don't they kind of
need to put him in a conservatorship
kind of if you're just adopted that
there's no
does nothing happen to be adopted at 18.
you can but it's it's purely just for
like for coolness her emotional like
yeah at least I think I could be wrong
in a separate statement he denied that
uh the legal representation denied that
the twois had controlled o'hare's NFL
deals despite being his legal Guardians
he's negotiated his own contract with
the NFL he's hired and fired his agents
the two ways have never had to sign off
on any of that he's done that all
himself
so it's well that's great that's good to
know right so is it over semantics like
is it over like just words like I
thought I was adopted socially like
online like on social media everybody's
kind of attacking out here a little bit
being like this [__] lost all
his money yeah they think he got he they
think he went broke and that he like
yeah so the sentiment's actually against
him yeah oh that's what some that's what
some people are saying yeah yeah I'll
walk back here all my money but if it is
true that like he's had a good life with
the NFL and he's got a lot of money then
we all look dumb trying to fight for
someone with a lot of money to get more
money from people with a lot of money
yeah like we look silly it sounds like
too original exactly
taking advantage of yeah
like y'all all LED better lives than us
yeah that's tough bro but who do you
think's in the right
just say you don't have enough
information
of a valid opinion on it you know what I
think I don't have enough information at
the time oh I thought you're gonna make
a judge what if I think if the actions
of the family my lawyers that directly
led to him being in a position good
enough to end up in the NFL I think
everyone's happy like shut up
come on because even without the money
he played in the NFL he's in the NFL
like that's a mess they got him there 18
bro like sorry you weren't really
adopted but you ended up
the resources and the opportunity to
have they would have never found him
they would have never found him because
that's how he was able to attend the
school remember the little brother in
the movie was so cute and they had such
a cool friendship growing up I don't
know what's up with kids uh no dude oh
[__] whoa bro I'm just saying it seemed
like he had a good family bond with the
family remember it was it was a little
kid Michael or whatever but they were
having so much fun in the movie they
were like best buds it was like it was
like Robin it is a little bit telling
how the family's reacting where they're
just like oh we still love him like it's
fine like they're not they don't seem
mad about it and also uh
everybody like it doesn't seem like it's
that big of a problem to them they're
like okay conservatorship's done all
right we're done no conservatorship yeah
and all they have to do is like show
their finances and be like we didn't
cash out for the movie there you go yeah
sure that's enough evidence and he has
been saying it for a while that he was
unhappy about this this isn't like new
it's just now picking up it's apparently
been estranged from the family for like
10 years
that's what I want to know
right like what happened in that
relationship
it'll be on a blind side too I can't
wait for that one
hopefully that little kid's not grown up
huh